scintillation vials are designed to  safely hold samples for liquid  scintillation counting chromatography  gamma counting culturing and sample  storage they provide a high degree of  resistance to organic solvents  scintillation vials are used for assays  that use reagents that emit low energy  radiation when you see a descriptor like  24 to 400 the first number is the  diameter 24 millimeters and the second  number is the thread size 400. choose  amber glass if your analyte is light  sensitive and clear glass if it's not we  also have different cap options here at  filters paper is the least expensive for  standard samples pe offers more chemical  resistant and better sealing and ptfe  liners offer the best chemical  resistance